hey everyone did you just buy your first
tractor and are unsure what implements
to buy
stay tuned with us here at the clinch
river homestead because we're going to
talk about the top three
implements that you must have for your
farm
or homestead or your new tractor
purchase roll it
[Music]
okay so i think the very first implement
that we must talk about
is right here
[Music]
so this implement called a brush hog or
bush hog it's made by titan implements i
think it's their medium duty model
and it's a six foot brush hog i think
this is
probably the number one implement that
you're going to want to have for your
homestead
if you're enjoying the content you're
watching today and would love to see
more
hit that subscribe button and tick that
little bell you'll get notified on all
of our videos just like this
because every homestead has grass demo
and every homestead
has brush to clear and it's an ongoing
process so i think
this right here is your top one
must-have
number two
so the second must-have implement that i
think
every new tractor owner should have is
this beauty right here
here's a six-foot titan implements box
blade
it has a just as the term
refers it has a blade right in the back
of this thing here so that you can
scrape up the ground it also has rippers
on the front here
so that you can really dig into that
ground the other cool thing with the box
blade
you could use it as a reverse front end
loader so
not only can you pull with a box blade
but you can push
on the other end on the back side
because there's a blade on the back of
this too
it's amazing what you can accomplish
with a box blade
so if you have a lot of gravel if you
have a lot of dirt roads
or if you just have areas that you need
to clear on your property to make paths
with
this is probably going to be your number
one implement for that
so i think this qualifies as your number
two
implement that is a must-have on your
homestead
just the versatility that this thing has
so let's move on to number three
so the number three top implement that
you must have
for your homestead or farm now a lot of
people are going to say wait a minute
pallet forks what in the world am i
going to do with pallet forks well let
me tell you something
that thing right behind me there that's
a grapple
pallet forks can do a lot of the same
work
that you can do with a grapple if you
need to pick up
logs if you're picking up brush
heck if you got to pick up big bales of
hay
pallet forks can do it if you need to
move
a trailer or something with a hitch on
it
you can put a ball on the front fork and
use the front end of your tractor
to move that implement around or that
trailer around
the other thing that these pallet forks
are really awesome
is they're adjustable and most of your
pallet forks are adjustable
so you can move these in or out
depending on
what you need to use it for so this
right here
is a titan implement pallet fork
my top three must-have for your farm
homestead or your new tractor purchase
so we're gonna wrap up the video today i
hope you got some good information out
of it
if you'd like to see more content like
this hit that subscribe button
tick that little bell and for the
youtube algorithm smash that thumbs up
button
really appreciate you stopping by we'll
see you on the next one